-Performing "Cellophane,"
from her upcoming album
"Magdalene,"
please welcome, FKA twigs!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Didn't I do it for you? ♪
♪ Why don't I do it for you? ♪
♪♪
♪ Why won't you do it for me? ♪
♪ When all I do is for you ♪
♪ They want to see us,
want to see us alone ♪
want to see us apart ♪
♪ They want to see us,
want to see us alone ♪
want to see us apart ♪
♪♪
♪ And I ♪
♪ Just want
to feel you're there ♪
♪ And I ♪
♪ Don't want to have
to share our love ♪
♪ I try ♪
♪ But I get overwhelmed ♪
♪ All wrapped in cellophane ♪
♪ The feelings that we had ♪
♪ And didn't I do it for you? ♪
♪♪
♪ Why don't I do it for you? ♪
♪ Why won't you do it for me? ♪
♪ When all I do is for you ♪
♪ And didn't I do it for you? ♪
♪ Why don't I do it for you? ♪
♪ Why won't you do it for me? ♪
♪ When all I do is for you ♪
♪♪
♪ They're waiting ♪
♪ They're watching ♪
♪ They're watching us ♪
♪ They're hating ♪
♪ They're waiting ♪
♪ And hoping ♪
♪ I'm not enough ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-FKA twigs!
Oh, beautiful!
"Magdalene" is out November 8th!